I fail to understand why every single
one you [ __ ] think that this is
a green screen if I had a [ __ ] green
screen you think this will be my
background I have a [ __ ] pterodactyl
a unicorn [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of each
other that's what
Oh what is going on YouTube now there is
a universal truth
ain't nobody likes to get pulled over by
the cops cuz the matter who you are the
moment you hear this you know your [ __ ]
oh this is my I know I'm [ __ ]
yeah I'm telling right now the moment I
hear sorry I pull over for no goddamn
reason yes Dave Chappelle it spread my
butt cheeks lift myself yeah
buzz it all honestly where I grew up we
all know that if you're black Mexican or
Asian you better shut the hell up before
you get a nice stick up your ass one
time a cop pulled me over and he called
me a chick and then she confused the
hell out of me because you know you was
Asian
slow down shake who call it aren't you
Asian hey my blood is red white and blue
and especially what what the but you
know observing and growing up with this
[ __ ] there was always one group that
avoided this social is a psycho
construct and those [ __ ] aren't you
girls could you [ __ ] get away
with everything
oh it's amazing when you begin with a
cute face and titties huh I act it easy
don't work for me this titty [ __ ] the
[ __ ] out of somebody we're not though
this may not work all the time you know
that there is a male officer and a cute
girl let's go go get away with a lot of
[ __ ] for example if said cute girl gets
pulled over she might start off the
conversation with an obvious question
like this hi officer
is there anything wrong you know why I
pulled you over ma'am
then she'll go in a compliment that'll
make the [ __ ] stutter it's just
I love men in uniform and
so handsome got lost some nice members
some damn rain the dumbest excuse for
why she was beating will start to make
sense
Oh mache done yet put my cupcakes are
melting now feel the [ __ ] deal
then watching be like you poor thing you
weak [ __ ] it's amazing what a little
flirting can do for you when you are a
cute ass girl and I'm not mad at you go
on with your fat cells use your tool
wisely but my problem is why I got one
for me because just like her it started
off with a question well by the great
eye of Sauron what do we have here
doesn't seem to be a problem officer
I feel the Bridget compliment officer I
just love me a man in uniform my god
what are those do for your eyes cuz they
look like a beautiful little [ __ ] I
wasn't done yet
come on me come on yo right there
Oh new cheese baby right on your lips
god damn hmm well big you liked it
[ __ ] me hey what is going on YouTube now
that was a collaborative video with
Julie's on now she shot that video a
while ago but um I was supposed to make
a video off of it but you know that
caught your mouth [ __ ] what can I say
[ __ ] it but but yes as you can see this
is one of my newer vlogging cameras it's
pretty dope on looks kind of cool kind
of like flippy and Schneider ship her
but thank you guys for tuning in and I
know you guys have been wondering
where's all the funny fat fits well
guess what I'm still shooting that short
film and we're still impressed we're not
shooting we're in pre-production for
right now and we're shooting it next
week so it's hard for me to do two
videos a week once again I'm a one-man
team so come on give me a break but yeah
but the short film that I'm shooting is
um it's gonna be majority in Korean
which is kind of a big deal yeah it was
hard as fun to write so just uh be
patient with it and you will see it
coming out soon maybe in a month maybe
in a month or two I don't know but be
patient but yes you guys
see you guys next Sunday not Wednesday
because funny fat bit will not be up
again but I'm still on that funny fanfic
grind make sure that you're still on at
two because I will be coming back with
the [ __ ] fury yes I'll see you all
next time whatever we're not testing me
right now during the middle of this [ __ ]
you know text me [ __ ] and I
touch the right mmm mmm